this man is very significant in the
success of the AT&T Pebble Beach pro-am
it's Clint Eastwood and good to talk to
you again Clint how are you good dad how
you feeling I feel great yeah why do I
look bad no it was last year I was
worried about yeah I don't you had the
flu last year I did I had the flu missed
the whole tournament the first time in
quite a few years but this year I stayed
away from the flu nice
I stopped shaking and you just give
knocks to people what's the sport you
loved growing out that you played I like
swimming a lot I like swimming I taught
swimming in the Army for two years and
swam there that was my favorite sport if
you didn't become an actor what would
you have done I don't know I don't know
you never know but you know it takes you
in different directions sometimes I came
became an actor by accident I was going
to Los Angeles City College GI Bill and
some friend of mine said you know I'm
going to an acting class this evening
would you like to go and I said I don't
think so he says a lot of pretty women I
said okay I said I'll go just kept on
going what what was the movie where you
kind of felt like you arrived like okay
I sort of know what I'm doing or I'm
really good at this
was there one like a moment no never had
one it's just you know I did a series
for six years I did I went to Italy it
did some Italian westerns and those were
fun to do and they they took off so you
know I did everything kind of followed
suit but I've I think I started
directing in 1970 I kind of liked that I
thought this is something I can do just
after
you know if good rolls don't come along
pretend like I know what
but aren't you famous for not many takes
like it's that because being an actor
you know sort of I don't think there's
any reason for that I just I'm very I
have a good habit of being decisive so
that's that works for me
sometimes your toussis decisive and you
read something and you wish you and very
rarely
we're friends with Jerry Ferrara and he
said that when he worked with he said
you know get it right get it quick yeah
let's get out of here it's a little bit
too overhyped that reputation because
guy is that if it isn't going well you
think do as many takes as it takes but
if you if things are going splendidly
and you try to keep the set very quiet
and smooth everybody has a nice a nice
feeling of camaraderie there talking to
Clint Eastwood new movie it's called the
5:17 to Paris and you use real-life
heroes who stopped the terrorists in in
in that why were you getting real-life
heroes as opposed actors Willie they had
a book on it and I was very interested
and they were at the time they were this
was a couple years ago so they were like
22 years old and they stopped this
terrorist attack on a train going from
Amsterdam down to Paris and it it was it
was quite it quite a risky thing because
the the the person that they were up
against at a ak-47 a 9-mil us the
nine-millimeter pistol plus a knife he
should be well armed and he could have
done a tremendous amount of damage on
that train but these fellows stopped him
and without regard for their own safety
what was it about that that you just
said I want to make a movie about it
well it just seems like it's such a
different deal three guys you know
backpacking around or looking around
Europe daddy a good time and then all of
a sudden you know fate takes a strange
turn and they it's just sometimes you
just never know what you're gonna do in
a situation like that you have to use
your imagination if you that what would
you do most the time you probably hide
under a chair yeah I know your desk I'd
hide behind this chair these guys did
did you do you realize you're
intimidating like there's an inn you you
know that comes with sort of your
character or who you are
I don't you're not that way in real life
I'm assuming but I think that there's
this intimidation factor when when you
arrive you know that I don't know about
that yeah we do I mean I don't know what
it is but you're just like Clint
Eastwood's coming in even though you
know you're an actor but your
personality
I'm sure off-screen is not anyone to
send around a long time that would
probably you know see these come you
know my guys were like uh you know
should we look him in the eye like the
like they were they've done something
bad here Clint maybe they have what do
people say to you on this what would be
the common thing that you hear on the
street I hear a lot of strange things I
can't give it an anecdote right now
because I don't I'll think of one
probably when I leave but you could make
my day and you know every film has its
it's it's lying you know it could be but
every every script usually has the line
like that he did yeah that's if I'm in
it if I'm not in it I usually think of
it from a different angle
what were those cigars that you smoked
and how long he was being called
Virginia and they were cigars about that
long they were use it I cut him in
pieces well so they're footlong yeah
they're made in Italy they and if you
smoked one really smoked one
long period of time you probably
wouldn't show up you turn green yeah
yes Paulie I mean is that my putting
green here Dan my dad and I used to
watch Outlaw Josey Wales over and over
and over and I talked my dad into
letting me try to back Oh after watching
you spittin Outlaw Josey Wales I was
nine yeah do you did you have to learn
how to spit in that movie yeah you just
practice it's like everything everything
in life yeah yeah I love that how good
golfer
were you at your peak never very good I
just I just enjoy playing I I've had a
few good rounds in my life but I've been
playing lately cuz I've been working so
but I love playing it's a great game and
great fun you play it at any time in
your life most most what's so special
about this place you know it's the kind
of place the Monterey Peninsula is a is
a great place I was raised in the Bay
Area but I came down here in the
military and I just said if I ever had a
extra dollar I'd love to have come and
live here and so you know 20 30 years
right here I did well what do you have
another movie in the on desk on decks
nothing at the moment no I'm just
reading how much how many scripts do you
get Oh quite a few
but I do you know you have to search for
something to suit you and there either
as a performer or as a director most of
the time is the director
in recent years because you know the old
you get your rolls get less less good
ones come on what happened to the car in
Gran Torino I have it you got to keep it
nice yeah do you take it better keep it
over there yeah do you take it out no
it's it's in the car Museum on the
Warner Brothers lot oh thanks Batmobiles
and all these different films and that's
in there too we recreated the Escape
from Alcatraz we we went out there when
the san fran went in san francisco
hosted the Super Bowl yeah yeah we went
out and recreated them yeah it didn't it
didn't match up with the movie him just
let her know it did yeah we shot it in
black and white and we we slipped out of
Alcatraz it's interesting we filmed out
there at night a lot and one night I
went up into the main cellblock and just
sat there by myself and it's weird it's
a weird feeling it's creepy and you hear
noises yeah man yeah yeah we got a
little freaked out we were glad to get
off there
yeah hey we're glad to get off that was
good hey it's great to see you and are
you playing tomorrow no you're just out
I don't play well you got your glove won
so you were playing today we played the
little shootout down there find a seven
hole all links are five holes I guess it
was five holes and my team against Bill
Murray team and we won we prevailed
we're rolling in money Clint thank you
it's great to see you okay and thanks
for joining us for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]